hi guys it's silver at again and today
I'm actually going to build a skyscraper
but before I do that I need to finish
this little building real quick because
I just needed something over here see
that's something that I'm kind of kind
of getting towards now is that when I
have areas that I haven't built anything
on yet I just feel like I need to build
something over here and it doesn't
really matter what so I just built me
like not as amazing buildings as I would
have liked to though to be very honest
of course your town is you your average
town is not full of nice buildings quite
the contrary I think most cities I
mostly exists out of very ugly buildings
especially outside the downtown area but
at this point I just felt like hmm I
need some wear something over here I
have no clue what this could be like a
little office something as something
like that it doesn't really look like a
house anyway it's not like I really get
houses in this downtown area but it's
not all that bad and at this point i
figured i would try making it look
better with these beams on the roof and
i guess that kind of worked out but then
I felt like there were too many beams
and I just decided to go with this and I
think at this point I just felt like mmm
i want to add something to this building
like little arcs little details that
make it look a bit better but it just
nothing really worked out so i went with
a chimney in the end and that's pretty
much that building now at this point I
felt like I don't want to have any
buildings on that side because I want to
have something from which you have a
really nice view of the city and those
buildings in front of the road there so
I just thought to myself well I might as
well I might as well make a little park
with a fountain in the middle with some
nice trees and stuff like that so I'm
just going for that I guess with nice
paths like that and then I realized I'm
not going to have a path leaning there
anyway so I'm just going to have those
couple of parts also this is probably
going to be the um well yeah probably
i'm not going to actually continue with
the town over there i'm just going to
make a forest there and some road with
something but i don't think i'm going to
continue with it into that direction now
of course as you all know i love flowers
so at this point i just went crazy with
all the flowers because they're they're
awesome and
I also felt like adding some hedges
because they're cool and that kind of
worked out and then I wanted a little
Bush over there but couldn't really find
anything so I just decided to go with
that thing in the end and at this point
and whoa that was a weird skip and that
well now i'm actually going to build a
skyscraper though and i might want to do
some explaining about the skyscraper
because as you might see it's kind of a
weird shape the idea is basically it
consists out of two squares which
obviously one of them is kind of more
like a diamond one of them is diagonal
and the other one is just straight so
they kind of intersect and one of them
is made out of glass and the other one
is made out of bricks and does have the
normal windows and then at the end I
want to create some kind of a special
spire but you'll see that at some point
and I might think well that's not very
high well the point of doing this is
just to make a base and then copy paste
it like this to create a large tower and
at this point I felt pretty safe with
the height of it so just decided to add
a cornice and start work on the spire
and I love doing spires for for
skyscrapers the only the only thing to
it is the fact that sometimes you just
end up with a spire that you really love
like in this case I really like it and
sometimes you get you just end up with a
really ugly spire and I hate it when
that happens but thankfully I actually
like this one and well the spire is
actually where the hair-pulling begins
because you have to combine all the
little diagonal pieces and it turns into
one big chicks or and have to make that
spire but at this point you can really
see the shape of the building and I just
kind of looks at it and I felt pretty
content with it so I'm just I just
decided to go with this I just really
like the idea of the glass coming out
and just being a little bit higher and
then having that diagonal thing on top
of it it kind of reminds me well this
building is actually not really based on
any building in real life but it was
inspired by one canada in london and the
message to him in frankfurt so that's
pretty cool of course it does have that
little well well it's it's a ruse pie
that's not like many spires it's very
straight and diagonal in a sense and I
actually thought of calling this the
prison but I'm still not really sure
about doing that but yeah this is also
one of the hair-pulling parts where you
have to add in all the little frames
because of course you don't want to have
lose glass fame but at that point the
tower is pretty much finished so I
decided to just create a little entrance
area with a neoclassical entrance
thingamajig because i love neoclassical
and it's not going to be too big it's
not really going to be like a tower that
stands in the middle of a pretty large
building it is going to be this one
entrance area that I'm actually going to
work on the rest of the surrounding is
just going to be trees or grass or
something like that I don't know exactly
but yeah I really like the look of this
and of course this entrance area is
going to be very straightforward just as
simple classic well when you even call
those things it's kind of like a like a
Greek temple in the sense and at that
point oh wait yeah of course I to remove
that large beam because it was kind of
sticking through them through the door
there but yeah I really like this and of
course I'm going again with these
windows from the main street set and I
really have to watch out with that
because I'm almost over using those
things and I don't want to over use any
set but it's just that those windows
goes so well with the entire classical
theme ale you have had going on and they
have a kind of a better texture than
Ralphie to Windows Ralphie's clutter
classical set doesn't actually have any
windows in it anyway what it does have
windows that that have a war connected
to them but I don't want that of course
so at this point it's just little little
things like windows and other details
that I wanted to add to this but all in
all this tower is right now finished so
I hope you like it I at least do and
hope you also liked the video and see
you next time